the Israeli military has blown up the
house of a senior member of Hamas in the
occupied West Bank let's get the very
latest barard Smith is in rala Bernard
we've seen raids uh increase over the
last couple of days in uh the West Bank
what is the
latest well actually it was a much
quieter night in the West Bank in terms
of of raids there were some raids in
Janine but fairly typical for what
happened even outside of uh the current
uh state of war between uh Hamas and the
Israeli government but they did surround
one house of Salah alori he is
considered hamas's number two they've
surrounded his house in uh the village
of Aurora about 20 kilometers north of
rala that his house has been empty for a
long time um he is considered he's in
Exile Lebanese media suggesting he might
be in Lebanon and they blew up his house
the Israeli military taking it over
about 10 days ago and more a symbolic
really uh move by the Israelis to
destroy this house nobody living in it
and of course they really want allori
himself he's long been on a most wanted
list the Americans offered a $5 million
reward for information about his
whereabouts back in 2018 but he's never
been captured and is considered one of
the real main masterminds behind this
October
attack that Hamas launched into Israeli
territory thank you for that update
Bernard Smith there for us in romalo